animals that were trapped in this
underwater pocket cave that are now
unleashed like that's the plot of
piranha 3d right am I remembering that
correctly I remember that being that
plot it's also this plot 47 meters down
so 47 meters down uncaged is the sequel
the 47 meters down kind of in title only
because I mean let's face it it's the
brand right everything has to have a
brand it's Hollywood it's entertainment
what's the brand something needs a brand
if it's gonna stand out the stick to the
brand the brand is the name 47 meters
down without it it's just a shark movie
that doesn't have anything to do with 47
meters down so it's like they had this
script that was this shark movie it was
like alright we'll just call that the
sequel to 47 meters down and 47 meters
down uncaged this group of high school
girls that go off grid and they do cave
diving in these underwater ruins in
Mexico and there's sharks down there
flying sharks and they're terrorizing
them and these girls need to escape the
movies come on I mean I get it we all
love sharks right like everyone loves
sharks sharks have a weak like Jesus
Christ himself has a weak and Good
Friday to Easter Sunday but sharks they
get a whole week new Messiah
20:19 Jaws but it's just a generic
monster movie or generic shark movie or
generic underwater things are trying to
kill us movies like the original 47
meters down at a point I kind of got
bored but I got where they were going
for they were treating it like a
thriller who's very claustrophobic there
were only two people down there so you
had enough dialog to go back and forth
but there weren't so many people to
where it's like I would strengthen
numbers is working for you and now it
doesn't feel as perilous this movie goes
against that funny because you're in
these underwater caves you're in whose
underwater ruins it should feel more
claustrophobic but there's so much light
it doesn't feel as claustrophobic as
just the darkness of being 47 meters
down I don't even think they are 47
meters down about 20 but really there's
strength in numbers in this movie there
are a few people together so you're like
oh it's not as scary it's not as
claustrophobic it's not as isolated
feeling which okay they're not going for
thriller they're going for what the
movie is which is monster movie so these
girls need to start biting it right like
they need to start dying that's why
they're there
and at a point they do but there was
this one part where someone just like oh
my god she's dead and I was like I'm not
gonna lie I don't even know who that was
like the next scene I was like okay it
was that one but I at the time didn't
help me at the time so yeah generic is
what I would use to describe this movie
was just kind of a generic underwater
monster movie or it's like oh I got to
survive while we're getting picked off
oh they're blind sharks that's a twist
not enough of a twist I mean it could
lend itself to some cool stuff and they
use it in the movie a little bit but not
to the extent that they could like
really in the end when the sharks come
in after someone they're still like
screaming and flailing it's like you're
just calling the shark to you there was
one cool scene where they use sound to
distract the sharks but that was the
scene I'm rambling so I don't know how
long this video is gonna be but I've
said what I needed to say like we all
have those days right those days we were
like I'm not even gonna try today I'm
just gonna phone it in at my job you
show up enough to do the job you're
clearly just kind of sleepwalking
through the whole day it's like that but
an entire film production you don't get
attached to anyone you don't care about
anyone a couple times they actually
quite literally do jump the shirt I
guess is still figuratively I'll be
there sharks in the movie no one
actually physically jumps over one that
I remember this movie did not grab me it
kind of checked out at a point you know
the whole monologue had just had about
floating through your job that was me
watching this I would say I'm just not
gonna remember this one in t-minus one
day ya already forgot so what's the
cheesiest shark movie you've ever seen
like usually I'm like what's your
favorite this no no we're going in the
opposite direction give me the cheese
whatever it is whatever you didn't
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]